Trick house this night been for you so
far yeah just I just got here but yes
that was Drake right before winning best
rap song for his hit God's plan God's
plan God's plan I definitely did not
think I was winning anything Drake beat
out Travis Scott
Kendrick Lamar j-rock and Eminem in the
category but he took a moment to call
out the Grammys in his acceptance speech
we play in an opinion based sport not a
factual based sport look the point is
you've already won if you have people
who are singing your songs word for word
if you're a hero in your hometown if
look look if there's people who have
regular jobs who are coming out in the
rain in the snow spending their
hard-earned money to buy tickets to come
to your shows you don't need this right
here I promise you how you already worn
despite getting cut off mid-speech Drake
had more to say when eats he caught up
with him backstage Drake is there
anything else you want to add to that
speech yeah they cut you up yeah yeah
yeah I want to say the Mayor of Toronto
needs to turn to CN Tower Gold tomorrow
I'm chroming bored are you stupid I eat
down so you're excited